[Music]
[Applause]
hard played by holliday
you have to think durant will get the
ball here on this play possibly a post
up
opportunity hardened waiting too long
will crush the defense by the walking
dog durant fires and
hits with the shot clock running down
he hits him downtown four-point lead for
the next
his holiday on the drive gets him over
to lopez and he puts it down
good play by holiday two-point game
44 seconds remaining in the fourth
good pressure here by the box and harris
looking at steve nash calls for time
so lumets have one timeout remaining
as do the bucks and this was just a poor
possession harden dribbled the clock out
but
was bailed out by kevin durant not an
easy
shot makes it look easy one dribble
pull-up
and he knows it feels good
and on the other end a quick hitter
beautiful drive and dish
finding brook lopez inside and it's
going to come down to the stretch the
way these two teams are performing down
at the end of this game offensively but
kevin durant
played the entire game
it's been a legendary performance and
will it be a legendary finish
remains to be seen kevin durant with
17 of his 46 points here
in the fourth quarter
he has played every minute in this game
five the series is called even at two
[Music]
game six coming up in milwaukee on
thursday night
if there's a game seven it will be back
in brooklyn
on saturday night
i mean just an incredible game here
marv and i think obviously durant will
get the ball on this possession
maybe a a double pinned down maybe a
dribble handoff jeff green's
comes up with the loose ball and is
fouled
with 15.3 to go in the fourth
and an untimely turnover on a beautiful
move by middleton but once again
jeff green his presence fumbled the ball
by giannis who had a dunk opportunity
and jeff green able to secure the
turnover and get the ball to that man
kevin durant who has 46 and talk about
some
passion and emotion james harden
displaying it there
understanding what's at stake here
durant
11-13 at the line
and a three-point brooklyn lead
[Applause]
marv the bucks only have one timeout so
they may try to get it in quickly
and get down the court for a quick two
or three opportunity
four point game here comes giannis and
he's
fouled by
this is the second rebounded by durant
he's tied up
and fouled by both odetsukumbo and
middleton and durant upset
he was virtually put into a headlock
so that means the rant will go to the
line
for two with 11 and 5 10 seconds
and fittingly right there that rebound
ended up in the hands
of kevin durant who gets a chance to
shoot
two free throws for 50 points
right now a lot of pushing and shoving
inside it looked like griffin and tucker
got banged up and
durant a little frustrated that oxytoco
was grabbing a little
too strong but 50-point possibility here
for duran
incredible 12 for 14 at the line
the nets lead by three
[Applause]
11 and 5 10 seconds remaining
well he's if he makes this next free
throw it's a two possession game
for milwaukee durant wants that shot
back
for sure it's a big free throw right now
by kevin durant
[Applause]
one or two at the line and the bucks
will take their final
timeout to rant one shy of his playoff
career high of 50 points
so the nets do have a timeout today
one of the great scores in the history
of the nba
kevin durant took over here in this
second half
facilitating getting his 10 assists
making plays
doing it all over the floor mall
tough shot after tough shot after tough
shot
not taking a break at all 48 minutes
the only thing he did the only mistake
was missing that free throw
but other than that a textbook legendary
iconic performance with his team they're
back against the wall
so much at stake kevin durant
incredibles harder for the pucks
what do you do kevin durant or one of
your good free-throw shooters
all right here's middleton with the
catch and shoot three
rebounds shot it and
that will do it as shabbat was fouled
with 6.5
remaining so landry
shot it will go to the line
as i better cumbo has fouled out
he parts with 34 points 12 rebounds
four assists and as you said earlier
marv giannis gave it as all i mean
just an incredible performance his
effort 42 minutes
left it all on the floor but just not
enough
against kevin durant in these nets a
good foul shooter 86
during the regular season
[Applause]
and i'm stunned right now marv i mean
milwaukee
was in control and then kevin durant
took over
with a legendary playoff performance
just incredible so burnett's
bounced back
[Applause]
game six back in milwaukee thursday
night
brooklyn trailed by as many as 17 points
with just under seven minutes remaining
in the third quarter
and they outscored the bucks by 23
after that i mean it's it's incredible i
keep saying that but it is
the thing you worry about though going
back to game six
can the bucs team mentally and
emotionally recover
after being up so big and losing in this
fashion